[Music]  damned to an eternal life of torment  revenants true purpose is finally clear  once one of the deadliest assassins in  the Outlands the apex gains now satiate  his endless bloodlust his power to  silence the talents of opposing legends  negates their advantages and ability to  escape not found by human limitations he  can quickly maneuver to strike with  violent efficiency but revenants  ultimate power is the true embodiment of  his horror wait until you see what  happens next you can summon a dog totem  that can protect any Legend for a short  time allowing them to escape death  we're prepared the dark death is coming  and he's coming for you  [Music]